as you may have heard yesterday CNN
parted ways with anchor Don Lemon I'm so
thankful to have worked alongside him
CNN this morning already looking
different after Monday's dramatic
shake-up I think it's a tough tough
position to be in Don lemon's name wiped
from the show's logo we wish him the
best his now former co-host Bobby Harlow
and Caitlin Collins addressing his
ousting at the network one day after the
longtime anchor said he was blindsided
and stunned so I want to step back for a
moment and take a quick look at how we
got here that's Don in his final
broadcast Monday morning unaware he was
just hours away from a bombshell well
good morning everyone it is Tuesday
April 25th we do begin though with news
about this show in a statement CNN CEO
Chris Licht thanked Don for his
contributions over the past 17 years Don
will forever be a part of the CNN family
of course Dawn was a big part of this
show over the last six months he was one
of the first anchors on CNN to have me
on his show that's something I'll
obviously never forget what else might
be unfair forgettable well ET has
learned that CNN staffers found out in
real time as the news broke leaving
everyone floored by Don's exit neither
side is disputing that Don Lemon found
out he was fired from his agent CNN is
saying well if Don had wanted to he
could have come into the office and had
a meeting maybe don did not want to have
that so he decided to go public instead
yeah Don immediately fired off a
response calling out the cable news
Giant on Twitter saying I would have
thought that someone in management would
have had the decency to tell me directly
Don was one of my first friends here at
CNN I'm so thankful to have worked
alongside him and for his support for
nearly 15 years here what happened there
because it seemed like he had weathered
another storm I was not very surprised
to see Don Lemon removed at CNN in fact
what surprised me was that he was able
to stay there for so long Dawn's firing
comes after a blistering expose alleging
he exhibited a pattern of troubling
treatment of women and unprofessional
Antics and remember when he he was
pulled off the air for making this
sexist comment if you Google when is a
woman in her prime it'll say 20s 30s and
40s are you talking about Prime for like
child preparing
it was pretty clear that new management
was not going to be a fan of Don Lemon
and yet he was moved from Prime Time To
The Morning Show and now clearly this is
more than a demotion it was a
termination I've set across from him
countless times and I know he's a really
talented broadcaster so I think he's
going to have a number of options out
there as for Don's former gig well the
news never sleeps and back to work we
are so proud of the dedicated team that
works around the clock to bring you the
news every morning and our priority is
you the viewer we're grateful you
welcome us into your home each morning
absolutely and of course this morning we
want to keep it with the focus on the
news of where that belongs so let's get
to it